Let me show you the app we're going
to create in this lesson called
Pitch Perfect.
Pitch Perfect allows you
to record your voice and
play it back with various sound effects.
Including changes to speed,
pitch, and even reverb and echo.
Let's run it on the iOS Simulator so
that I can show it to you.
The first screen simply prompts
you to record your voice.
Hear at Udacity,
we believe that asking questions
is one of the best ways to learn.
Judge a man by his questions
rather than his answers.
Now you can see Pitch Perfect has moved
us to the playback view where we can
choose to playback my voice using
a variety of different sound effects.
Let's try listening to it really fast.
>> Judge a man by his questions.
Rather than his answers.
>> How about what I would
sound like as Darth Vader.
Judge a man by his questions.
Rather than his answers.
>> This app is a lot
of fun to play with.
But more importantly, you will learn key
iOS development concepts along your way.
It will also be the start of your
journey as an iOS developer.